[Music]
so let's get going
one game 1826 okay we're playing black
yeah let's see how um
let's actually play a sicilian it's been
a while okay so
unfortunately we're facing a c3 sicilian
and um
i'm going to play an interesting
sideline
that was introduced to me many years ago
by by i think my first coach showed me
this line
so as you guys know
knight f6 is one main line d5 is the
other main line
and this sideline actually starts with
d5
but after e takes d5 instead of the
conventional queen takes d5
which is
obviously
um which is obviously typical
there is a second move that's not well
know whoa knight f3 well scratch
everything
i i don't think i've ever seen that move
before in my life
i mean i guess his idea is d4 he goes
queen a4 check and then picks up the
pawn he's trying to be cute but
obviously he's
he's going to lose
like five tempi
swinging his queen around from place to
place so obviously we should take the
pawn
queen a fortrex he thinks he's cool by
doing all this but the reality is this
is just going to backfire very very
quickly
so how should we respond to this you
know how should we
position our pieces given that he's
going to play queen takes c4 there's a
there's a muppet here most popular wrong
answer i think some of you may be
tempted to go bishop to d7
but bishop d7 is awkward it's passive
and it's awkward and you don't need to
prod him to play queen takes c4 he's
going to probably do that anyway
actually wait a second
yeah okay so i noticed that yeah queen
takes c4 he had knight e5 in that
position but
that wasn't dangerous we had bishop d7
there
okay so now obviously we go knight f6
and attack the queen and black has
pretty much a clear advantage
so this is where we're brother of the
baboon
yeah that is that is not the greatest
opening so back to a4 wow
and this guy
um so now of course he creates a pin
against the knight
and
there's no need to let that pin bother
us let's just go bishop to d7
you know this this i've talked about
this before this move
uh is passive in certain situations but
in other situations is perfectly logical
bishop b5 is
quite a short-sighted move
what should we do here
what should we do now
and this is a very good move to pair
with bishop d7 we go a6 we force the
bishop to move
if he takes the knight he loses yet
another tempo he gives up a good bishop
yeah i don't really see the rhyme or
reason behind any of what he's doing
uh bishop c6 bishop c6
and now his light square i mean look at
these light squares
particularly on this diagonal we're
going to try to not even let him castle
if possible
and when your opponent plays like this
it's important
i think to
recognize that you should already be
looking very early on for ambitious
moves don't let him complete his
development because that's exactly how
your advantage is going to fizzle out
uh
i can sort of sense that he's totally
losing track of the game so
the sort of
conventional approach here would be to
go e6 and bishop d6
and complete your development black is
better there but then he castles and it
would be a real shame if if he
stabilized his position after such
terrible opening play
so a couple of moves come to mind in an
attempt to punish him
the first one in the move that we're
going to play is queen to d3 this is a
textbook move
not only are we preventing him from
castling but we're freezing the d3 the
d2 pawn in place
his only real move is to play queen e2
here and that leads me to an important
point because a lot of people would look
at that position say well the queen
traits clearly got to be bad for black
because
since um we have this huge initiative
since we have this huge initiative
we don't want to trade queens queen
trade is bad for blackit
by definition it basically lessens the
initiative but it doesn't necessarily
work that way
uh the trade can be good because
your minor pieces and your rooks could
combine to fulfill the role that the
queen was fulfilling i.e controlling
those light squares and preventing white
from developing and when your opponent
can develop in an end game that's just
as important as
him not being able to develop in the
middle game
if that makes sense so we'll have to
decide how we play it after queen e2
there's a lot of different moves the
simplest is to play bishop b5 and the
bishop takes d3
and the bishop basically replaces the
queen there
but
the problem is at the end of that line
he's got a pretty nasty move that
somehow
stays you know keeps him in the game
that bishop on d3 is vulnerable to the
move knight e5 now he goes 95
immediately
look at the king you'll notice the king
is very vulnerable we'll play queenie
for check he does play queen e2
so
let's consider our other options other
than bishop e5
what are our other options well
i think i see what we should do here
and
the correct move i think is quite
paradoxical because
you guys might be thinking of dropping
the queen back to d5 but that kind of
defeats the purpose then we we allow him
to go d4
um if we go c4
then after the queen trade it may seem
like his bishop is um entombed but it's
not he can go b3 can fianchetto it to a3
he can sort of work around the edges
okay so that doesn't seem to work but
we're assuming here that we can't take
his queen
but we can i think that the best thing
to do here is just to take his queen
force his king out into the center where
it's incredibly vulnerable particularly
to checks like bishop b5
uh but instead of going bishop b5 check
immediately i think there's no need for
that either
we we want to make the most flexible
move i'm trying to play very flexibly
let's just castle
just developing our pieces
and we're keeping all of the advantages
of the position
we're keeping his king weak we're
developing our pieces efficiently i'm
sure this is not the best that we could
do
but
i think it's good enough and see he
basically blunders upon immediately
uh going for 95 which looks aggressive
looks like he's attacking a bunch of
stuff but he's what has he missed
what has he missed
yeah bishop takes g2 i mean rook g1
bishop d5 and
his quote-unquote initiative fizzles out
and he's down a pawn of the terrible
position
so
this is a satisfactory approach that we
took here probably not the best but
definitely satisfactory
now he can play knight takes f7
bishop takes h1 knight takes he takes h8
but we're gonna trap trap his knight on
h a we're gonna drop that bishop back to
d5 cover the escape square on f7
and then we're going to pick up that
knight pretty easily on h we're going to
be a piece up there
stroke g1 bishop d5
c4 okay so we don't want to step back to
c6 because we lose the f7 pawn
so we do have the very convenient square
on e6
that's part of the part of the package
here
part of the package
okay knight c3 how should we
untangle it's weird talking about
untangling here because we're not even
really tangled up
we've got a couple of development
schemes that we could adopt here too
uh to get a nice nice development now g6
bishop g7 yeah is possible
but i'm more annoyed by the knight on e5
the knight on e5 is
is is uh the piece that i want to get
rid of right that's um that's one of the
things you want to get into the habit of
doing okay what are my priorities what
what is my top priority in any given
position and oftentimes it's going to be
just to eliminate whatever your
opponent's strongest pieces particularly
if he only has one good piece because
that really
that really kills whatever
chances he may have harbored so knight
d7 is simple and strong he's going to
take it we're going to take with the
rook
and then you know we're going to be in
phenomenal shape there
hopefully this is making sense so far
we're playing very simple chess nothing
extraordinary not the best but good
enough i think
well taking with the bishop is awkward
i'm not well i guess see what you can
take with the bishop and go e6
you know instead of taking with a rook
it's an interesting idea to take with
the king uh on on i actually really like
taking with the king
that's what we're gonna do can somebody
explain to me what the
the purpose may be of taking with the
king because it seems bad like why would
we block the
rook uh what's the point here the
develop the king for the end game so
where are we going to put it think about
this in terms of target squares what's
the king's target square
like not ea we don't want to just the
king in the in the end game it does not
have the same role that it does in the
middle game definitely c6 we walk
thinking up to c6 it defends c5
uh it's out of the way it's on a light
square so the the dark squared bishop
can't bother it and neither can the
knight so it's a ideal square for the
king then all we're going to have to do
let's walk the king up to c6 is develop
this bishop efficiently once we do that
our pieces are developed we can proceed
to the main plan which is probably going
to be attacking this d3 upon us and
surrounding it and winning it eventually
okay so how are we going to do that
there's a couple of methods of
untangling and developing this bishop
um the method that i like particularly
is to move this bishop out to f5 attack
the spawn
and then move the e pawn out perhaps to
e5 and freeze the spawn even further
yeah we can play e6 too we can play e6
too
but i like the movie 5 because it
prevents him from
freeing himself with the move d4 and
i want you guys to notice that well i'm
sure some of you are thinking this
aren't you weakening the d5 square nah
because we can drop the bishop back to
e6 at any moment on demand
and we'll be totally fine there okay
rook g5 i saw it's not as scary as it
looks if we drop the bishop back we lose
the pawn but what move is available to
us here
yeah just g6 defending the bishop
and then we can chase the rook away with
h6 or f6 whatever we choose he's
probably going to go knight d5 eurobeam
i guess
with a bunch of pseudo-activity looks
like he's getting active but we just
chase his pieces away easily and then we
start steamrolling him as you guys will
see i'm anticipating the move knight d5
but this guy is good he's defended quite
well uh he has not given us anything
easy in the end game
so i'm pretty happy at that
yeah knight d5 h6 get out of there
bishop b6 get out of there
right
knight f6 get out of there
oh bishop g7 was better though because
now he has knight g4 ah but knight g4 we
can even just take it
no now he goes knight e4 okay
actually no do not go f5 so you see
always be careful i double check your
moves at all times
one sloppy move like this at this level
like f5
and
the effort of the entire game is
nullified because
it looks natural but because we played
h6 it weakened the g6 pawn
and as you guys can see he's got rook
takes g6 counter attacking the bishop so
you just have to be a little bit more
careful than that
and
having seen that we can fix the problem
first and then go f5 so how can we do
that well we don't want to go rook hg8
that's just an inefficient use of our
resources we don't want to consign an
entire rook
uh to the sole purpose of defending the
pawn so instead
but i'm not sure why you guys are going
h5
and bishop f5 defeats the purpose we do
want to play f5 it's just that we want
to defend this pawn first you push it
out to g5 then we play f5 and in
addition this constructs a more robust
uh pawn phalanx on the queens on the on
the on the king's side so g5 is the best
of all of the worlds
it's pretty much
crushing here f5 is coming
c5 is well defended look at how nice our
king is it's protecting this pawn which
is turned out to be very important
now we can already start thinking in the
interest of time here of our potential
plan once we go f5
and the plan
uh i think stems naturally from
a careful
you know assessment of the position we
already know what white's biggest
weakness is
just looking at the position you should
be able to identify visually
what white's biggest and most attackable
weaknesses
and the way to attack it is also
incredibly common and you don't have to
reinvent the wheel here d3 the plan is
very simple we're going to stack our
rocks on the d-file
and some sort of tactic or breakthrough
is going to announce itself i think once
we do that
okay so b3
he's trying to secure
his position in preparation for this but
it's not going to help
so we can very safely play five we don't
need to play f4 so f4 would be
unnecessary because it would um
it would weaken the e4 square you know
be very careful about these pawn
advances because they might seem very
good in the moment but if they weaken a
square permanently they might not be
worth it and f4 is not going anywhere
you could play at any moment hideous
thank you for the ten
thank you phineas gage for the ten
gifted subs i really appreciate it
um
awesome support over the past couple of
days good to see thank you phineas
all right
good stuff good stuff
okay knight a4 doesn't do anything
double you see how efficiently we're
playing knight b2 who he's trying to
defend this pawn
the first thing i notice about this move
is that this knight is an undefended
piece
uh and because it's undefended i'm
already looking for ways that i can
exploit that and i see just the way to
exploit it
um
which is to do what
which is to go bishop f6
x-raying the knight i'm preparing of
course the devastating e4
opening up the attack on the knight and
the the attack on the d3 pawn this is
pretty smooth this is very easy
like the all of these moves are
incredibly natural if you know what the
general plan is now the situation has
changed
see and this is where things get a
little bit tricky because
his knight is no longer
able to access the e4 square okay i want
everybody to see that
um
and so what follow-up plan becomes more
doable and more
let's say more appealing now that his
knight has no access to e4 not even
close
yeah so f4 and then bishop f5 building
up the attack on the d3 pawn but before
we do that if we really want to play
clinically if we really want to
eliminate all of the counter play as
some of you guys have noticed the move
b5 is excellent because it stops the
knight from coming out to a4 and maybe
re-tooling rerouting to c3 so we
literally squeeze the life out of white
here completely
and then when when we're ready we're
going to play f4 bishop f5 and then
maybe e4 goes f3
okay so that doesn't change anything
let's go f4
let's safely go f4 now this creates two
possibilities besides bishop f5
we also prepare h5 and g4 adding to the
pressure on the king side so the way to
win these positions as you guys can see
is to build up the pressure on all sides
of the board queen side center king side
and at some point something is going to
announce itself some sort of a tactic
breakthrough or the breakthrough occurs
very naturally so here taking on h4
allows counter play with rook g6 i don't
see the need to allow any of that let's
just go bishop f5 eyes on the prize
if he takes it we'll take it
of course we could have taken on on g on
h42 but here this preserves all of the
advantages of the position g4 becomes a
serious idea now we have the h file in
addition and as nimsovich said
when one side is so cramped when the
position opens up that favors the side
with more space because you're more
easily able to get your pieces from one
side of the board to the other let's go
g4 if he goes rogue h6 we can go rook d6
kudos to my opponent amazing defense
he's finding like every resource to
complicate things but i mean his pieces
are so passive there's just nothing that
he can do
yeah this is a lot of fun this game has
been a lot of fun to play i mean it
reminds me of the good old days when i
was able to beat people like this but
of course when you're playing gms and
stuff like they're not gonna succumb
uh that easy not to suggest this guy has
succumbed easily
okay so what should we do how do we
actually
how do we actually enhance the pressure
we can push to g3 but i would i would
preserve the tension
um
and i would make a move here that may
seem a little bit weird
i would play
rook g8 just get the rook
to the open file because the file opens
up and i'll take with the rook so i knew
that the file was going to open up and i
got the rook there first the rook has
done its job on the d-file you don't
need two rooks on the default anymore
one rook is going to suffice but the
king side is open so now we need to send
some of our army to the king's side and
and prepare for the opening of the king
side if that makes sense there were many
ways to win the position this is just
one of them uh and i played a little bit
fast here in the interest of time now
notice that we're threatening bishop h
four check that as a classic discovery
against the rook
so
keeping an eye on the tactics here a b
is probably going to go here
yeah bishop h4 check and we win the
exchange finally we win some material
now the win is at hand
takes takes he's going to take and go
knight c4
yeah
um
let's throw in an intermediate check on
h2
connect the rooks and threaten rook h1
with a skewer
and now the game is actually over
i won't have time guys to analyze the
game step by step
let's give a check another check
uh because i do have to go but uh
you know maybe i'll i'll do it tomorrow
i'm just playing a little bit faster
because
again there's yeah
the guy can resign take steak stakes
king d3
e4
e3 i mean look at
we can even play f3 but we're going to
go e2
h1
check me
55 moves excellent game and uh not an
easy one kudus again to my opponent that
was a very good resistance so
i've written this down tomorrow um we're
going to start by by looking over this
game i'm gonna stream first half of the
day tomorrow
um
and uh it should be should be a fun time
so
all right guys yeah so uh sorry if today
was a little bit shorter than usual
as i said monday tuesday wednesday my
toughest days so
i need to preserve a little bit of
energy
and i'll see if i can uh
you know if my play is a little bit
better tomorrow because of you know new
inspiration so thank you guys appreciate
the support always um
uh thank you for hanging out
and uh
you know stay safe everybody
have a good rest of your tuesday
[Music]